it's so high I'm a demon Zeb I'm a
doctor science research earth nice and
my talk will be about how we can measure
the customer experience based on a
customer journey and how the use of
machine learning can empower it so I
will start with a little story about the
journey to the mall like every data
science story it starts it begins
somewhere in our neighborhood so about
two months ago on my way to the mall I
fell down and I broke my ankle
after realizing it was very bad and I
needed to spend all night at the
hospital and between my my and my
husband plans the doctor told me before
leaving the hospital
take your medicine come back in a week
and don't forget to bring form 17 -
lastly there's no way to say it in
English
so after not completing my first journey
journey to the wall I started my second
journey to get off the ship ahoy so I
call my family doctor told him what
happened and he told me listen you need
to call to another clinic you need to go
to another clinic upload the hospital
papers then wait another two days until
it will be approved and when it's going
to be approved you need to go again to
the secretary and then they will send it
to your mail or to your app accounts man
that was almost as bad as breaking my
ankle
so this is what my said this is what
nice does that's nice it is a leading
provider of software solutions enabling
organizations to improve customer
experience so I wonder what if you
petroleum use my project just journey
excellent score jess is a machine
learning metric that measures the
customer experience from the journeys
aims to identify processes with low
satisfaction Jess takes as an input the
interaction data of the service such as
duration of the survey of service the
sentiment the contact rains and intent
of the customer then uses them to build
journeys then we take these journeys we
enter them into a machine learning
algorithm which results with a score for
those journeys jeff's helps analysts to
drill down into business processes and
to identify processes with poor with
poor experience and to recommend
specific analyzes to specific areas and
to improve those processes so how it was
accomplished I was how it was
accomplished back on the old days 2018
after you finish your service you get a
survey to film when was the last time
you feel the survey let me guess it was
either when you had a really bad
experience or when you had an amazing
one so back to our story I went back to
the hospital and the doctor told me you
need to go you need to come back again
in two weeks and bring a dose of his
face but I said oh my god I'm not gonna
do it again and then I told him how hard
was and he told me at least then you
just need to use the app you don't need
to do even one comb I did it it was
amazing
and
my exam score went high so how is this
related to Python
so we extracting the data right from a
database and then we need to take this
data and transform it so everybody talks
about the amazing modeling models in the
pipeline but actually the main thing
that affair between use cases and data
science project is how you take the data
in its raw state long long text many
coms different scales and transform it
to something that the model can process
so I would like to recommend a very
powerful tool I use which is the
contacts form that takes
apply transformations for combined
features I will give you a very simple
example this is our data we have three
types of features we have text features
we have categorical features and we have
numerical features and let's say I want
to apply for each of those combined
feature different transformation let's
we say let's say for the text we want to
do vectorization for the numerical
wanted to do normalization and for the
categorical features we want to apply
one haute encoder in those four lines we
just does do this magic and it returns
us an array that the model can process
so in the end of the months we get our
paycheck not because we do data science
because we bring business value so just
enables our clients to increase
engagement and satisfaction of the
customers and decrease Charon and
complaints and this makes a lot of money
so I hope that in the future we will be
able to get office visor with less bad
feelings and let some everything up so
Python is a great tool and it has really
cool stuff in its use as I said to take
the data organize it and transform it
that's the main challenge we want to
solve real world
problems and are just to show a couple
''tis for science and sorry I'm not
disabled with my hand and top advanced
what you just need to use the app thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]